[Music]
for so many reasons
hello welcome to uoit's trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the other show you like a little
better than this one I'm stretched a
covered Joestar lawn Harris somebody
else friend from dope from the juice
world video from Anderson Anderson yes
but most importantly our na Anderson a
screen junkie welcome thank you you're
here you have not seen the honest
trailer now or spider-man far from home
no I have not movie have you seen far
from home you are in the film what did
you think about it I loved it it was
great I had a great time filming it and
a great time watching it and now it's
out for people to buy there you go nice
plug yeah buy it
get it in early we also for people click
off I think we also uniformly enjoyed
the film and yet we can't not make fun
of the Marvel movies yeah so we do they
being Marvel controlled opposition keep
those tests or does DC pay you guys to
make fun of Marvel and Marvel pay you to
make fun of air all the same reptilian
people Oh some joke
[Laughter]
so yeah so much of the conversation
around this film as they're writing it
was like Sony Marvel's Sony Marvel who
owned spider-man and it changed so many
times that we couldn't really write too
many jokes about it there was a there
was an a-hole earlier draft of this
honest trailer based on Disney and Sony
have broken up and spider-man is back
with Sony full time and you guys are
never gonna get what you want again and
this is the last glimpse of the glorious
days they were together and then
literally I'd written that went to sleep
woke up the next morning yeah the whole
thing was unusual to basically start
fresh cuz that no longer apply I mean
how are you feeling through all this I
mean I'm pretty exciting I'm excited I'm
happy I'm happy that the marriage is
gonna continue okay go one more picture
yeah is that whole process just like an
agent or a manager checking in every
other hours so and just being like
you're fine you're gonna be somewhere no
no it's fine
just waking up when they got back
together I just woke up and literally I
had like about 50 texts or ever than
being like you're welcome or congrats or
personally text message everyone in the
cast there's a phone tree it goes Tom's
and Day and Martin start
[Laughter]
also an Incredible Hulk so I think my
minds that might be even above dumb just
saying yeah just saying in my book in
our old s book that's a that's a real
sobering moment when people your age are
playing like teachers and parents oh
yeah that's how he felt in the first
movie he was like yeah I remember when I
was doing Freaks and Geeks and I was a
student like grow up and they become
teachers at their old high school the
teachers yeah that one was jarring and
then Aubrey Plaza as a mom in Chucky in
the nude is very jar yeah yeah but see
that is less to me because I feel like
everyone's like getting sobering to the
idea of like young moms yeah that's a
thing yeah so like it's like oh but she
could be a 26 year old mom that makes
sense
yeah she's got young energy yeah the
only character more depressing than
Flash Thompson is your character yes I
saw it I mean it was fun I just I was
bait they told us they gave us all the
cliche versions of what it was gonna be
it's like you grow up and become this
and then I was like oh cool and then
it's either video and it's like he's
just a shitty human being just like gets
nothing good for him what do people cast
you as such pathetic losers welcome back
to honest trailer therapy yes with that
said let's all take a group watch of the
honest trailer for spider-man farm home
and just yell out pause if you have
anything you want to pause and discuss
fantastic role picture
how many of those you actually get for
this movie probably hundreds yeah from
the students are not requests to
divorced parents arthelene where where
their kids means christmas comes an MCU
venture movie that's all about the tony
stark shaped hole in the universe uh are
you sure it isn't even wants to make a
spider-man movie you're not Iron Man
you're never gonna be Iron Man
[Music]
so pause oh how many films do we think
it's gonna take for them to never
mention Iron Man or Tony Stark again
probably zero right cuz frame or you
can't say no but like somebody's gonna
be wearing that armor right presumably
resume ibly I mean I think phase four is
probably that's where we're going to
figure out flash look I have known of
the Haab they tried to explain the Green
Goblin Hobgoblin generations to me and
I'm like I can't keep it all straight he
becomes one version of a goblin you're
gonna be yeah you were saying about my
arm and yet see I feel like they're
gonna do it like why would the Eternals
mention Iron Man okay fair enough but
like I guess in universe it's still
pretty fresh cuz like for lots of people
no time has passed since like Tony Stark
just died and then spider-man homecoming
came out right cuz this far from oh yeah
this is the final movie of phase four
three three right four is gonna start
with Black Widow so if we're gonna say
that this is like the Tony Stark dark
the Tony Stark
some slam poetry snaps thank you
this is like is this the end of Tony's
story this is the end this has to be the
end we can shut up about Tony Stark now
right I
this feels to me like a like a nice
little like a button at the end and now
we're the Tony Stark era has closed and
we're ready for the next I think is
chowder
I think of last night at times if I get
time joint mortgage dark yeah yeah
Morgan might get zonked around at a time
line and zoinks my word today so just
come back as a night away enrolled who's
like ready to fight okay yeah it might
happen let's get happy in that armor
happy
yeah Buster armor happy I yeah I dig
that I get you know as much as I was
like okay I just want a spider-man movie
I I get everyone still set I'm still
very sad about Prince and and I mean
like just died so I guess
thank you everybody can be sad for a few
more months and maybe you yeah I feel
like in this movie especially it really
felt like they're just Tony's just the
Uncle Ben of this version of spider-man
this is what any other spider-man movie
would be doing except it would be about
his guilt and his feet processing Uncle
Ben's dad yeah and in this one it's just
we've replaced his sort of mr. I guess
right they did know they wanted it in
homecoming we were like cool they skip
the Uncle Ben origin cuz we all know it
Tony probably should have made uncle
been a billionaire industrialist a
farmer that's Cliff Robertson from the
Sam Raimi films but he's a billionaire
industry yeah we still haven't met Uncle
Ben I guess we never will at this point
no you know we've seen his briefcase
yeah yeah well he's mentioned it in the
movies yeah like he's like after what
happened I think he has a line where he
says like after what happened with my
uncle or what happened to her
there was an Uncle Ben at some point
yeah she's like mentioned right we just
eaten like the tiniest detail of a line
yeah yeah yeah I think was it she was
like freaked out because he's gone all
the time and she was like after what
happened to your uncle she hurt he
apologized for always making her worry
after what happened to banners right
yeah yeah I think it was I think it was
to to Ned's character he was saying like
I can't do this to her after yeah
something right next season like far
from home I wasn't in that we were
flying from I think London to Prague and
I was on a plane with and he was just
alone I mean that's why I do a screen
junkies videos like let's keep watching
Marvel fans everywhere prepare they get
a feature-length dopamine rush all that
sweet sweet intro franchise consistency
indie drink tons of Iron Man
loads of n game they called it the blip
juicy kernels of phase four
I thought three having sweetness it was
top secret information yeah man
tantalizing feel like I'm forgetting
something oh yeah
spider-man goes on vacation these no
concept seems a little Disney Plus to me
wake me up when they get to space
Wakanda you don't you want to see space
Wakanda you did I mean yes we always
this is it's a lot of spider-man there
is a spider-man is at the
center of it I think that they there was
a little having their cake and eating it
too with the explanation of the blip you
know not that the whole movie needed to
be about that but like when everybody
pops back into existence they're like
and we call it the blip and like you
kind of get out of having to really
explain it because it's like a high
school news conference that had been an
endgame that was the best possible way
to do it just like a terrible style high
school news boom in the shot yeah
starting it with the Google know the
Getty Images yeah
I really like it they're constantly like
looking at the wrong camera to like it's
it's subtle but every shot they're like
what and yeah but I mean you know the
the thing that everyone brings up is
like well everyone that got flipped back
like that was on an airplane did they
fall into the ocean everybody but then
the whole explanation is that the Hulk
swish is like everyone returned safely
so if they're on a plane or something
like that I was reading if they're on a
plane they would be put safely somewhere
like they're not going to be in the
middle of the air who was the Hulk swish
like when Tony snaps it's like why
doesn't Gamora disappear man the magic
of the magic of character that's it's a
beautiful explanation yeah Wow look at
that yeah well you just killed the
premise of a million internet video
yeah no I loved calling at the play
because like what would you call you
wouldn't call it the decimation anymore
and all the stuff that everyone else was
calling it before endgame well they call
it the snap the snap snap no one knew
right that he snapped like who exactly
my point is this
besides Thor who was present for the
actual thing did he go around being like
guys it's called a snap snap I guess
that's what I'm curious about most and
maybe it can be like a Marvel one-shot
or something like that is like
explaining to someone in Peoria what
happened I think okay look there was
this alien who snapped a magic space
glove that's where your wife went the
Avengers took care of it in space gems
you know it was a whole thing but
everything's fine now don't worry
I would actually watch the Marvel short
where Mae talks about flipping back and
there's people living in her apartment
yeah they had like whole concepts for
four where people were gonna blip back
and we're what they would do and they
shot some of them but then I don't think
they they didn't put them I think that I
didn't I didn't have one or or I think
it existed nor days and that back in my
locker like by my locker and someone
else was there or I oh I remember
I wanted to I pitched the whole thing
for him to snap back on the toilet
perfect you just flipped back a whole
nother slate of YouTube videos do you
ever Laurie
I'd like to see like the 4-minute like
YouTube Vox explainer of the snap the
internet social media video like you may
have noticed your family's in have to
wait here's what happened I'm like 90%
sure we made that yeah alright let's
keep watching something ending up the
next episode of MCU hop aboard the kind
of team euro roadtrip sex romp not seen
since Euro trip road trip or sex drive
we're joined by his very own Stifler
teachers but from a 90s it's mine star
Mary Jane the why a reboot of debbie
downer glad we're doing this you know
they used to execute people on this
bridge as a mind-control intended to
create an army of the insane seems nice
I just hope she doesn't end up like his
other girlfriends my wife and I split up
two beds that a bed run yes baby um
Parker luck yeah I get the take of MJ
where it's like Mary Jane and we'll get
it in the hole yes we've got it wrong
I'm sorry we get things wrong sometimes
that's not Mary Jane it's my bed
Lon's bed my bed too you're meant to
everyone's bad thing it's like make sure
you call her Mary Jane what if his love
interest was like the opposite of Mary
Jane but like she's really depressed
she's got a problem I know I was
actually really hard like to come up
with a read for this because I did I
like this take on the character I think
it's kind of funny and so I was like it
was hard to come up with a way to like
really goof on it cuz I think they've
done a good job with it but as soon as I
thought of like oh she's kind of like
people say a normal thing and then she
says the bleakest versions gotta like
debbie downer and and as soon as I
realize you could do the horn sound
effect that was right so yeah so I think
a lot and I both agree on the first on
their first cut we were like I think we
can do a one and and we're good I had
always been just do it once and I pulled
those three clips like pick the best
yeah one oh I hate me laugh every time
so then we so we showed this Friday at
New York Comic Con and showing the
unfinished trailer I Oh
it's stressful it stresses me out I
ultimately like it but it stresses me
out
but every time every horn-like big laugh
and then hundreds AC wants someone
actually went Jesus one moment like that
per episode yeah yeah no I think we a
few episodes ago we were debating how
many fart noises is too many today we're
debating how consent
before I begin to say with the with the
fart noises I was always behind more
more farts yeah yeah no that's really I
mean I've never noticed that but that's
100% true yeah and then Martin Starr and
JB smooth just murdered that being
millions teachers yeah I liked his witch
obsession there was a whole thing I can
imagine I need 40 minutes of there's an
entire movie just from their point of
view about this whole entire thing and
the whole witches thing went way further
there was there was a moment or not
moments like he kept blaming mr.
Harrington saying his wife was a witch
and that she was cursing him and then
finally at the end in that moment when
the big monsters there it's like it's
like you know you have to sacrifice
yourself to the monster for us to be
safe and there's just there's just
Martin gone the funniest thing yeah if
you ever hear him on like a podcast or
an interview it's like there's one
question at the beginning and then the
next forty minutes watch spider-man
we all knew Mysterio was gonna be bad
guy when they said mister was in the
movie because it was gonna be a way that
wasn't for you guys Joanne Hall's
jawline and abs as the hero but what do
they know Jake Gyllenhaal from they're
not like Bob's and Kansas halfway where
like they sell one day love drugs and
that was Motown TAC team right I'll be
honest I read the script and it spoiled
everything for endgame for me yeah
because we shot that before and game had
even come out yet so we had to know
positively who died and who didn't and
they weren't even done shooting so I had
to know everything and which sucked cuz
I was like oh that spoils a movie but we
we I mean reading the script I was I was
surprised with the turn I was like it
went on long enough that I was like
maybe he's just gonna be good yeah it's
like it's past the midpoint when he
breaks bad yeah so yeah it could be like
a new twist but come on come on
sinister six you know you know fullness
was the actually if they had had a
villain that you would be like this
could be the main villain in a
spider-man movie that was a mysterious
maybe mysterious gonna be the good guy
they're fighting the fight for Sandman
it was the fact that the villain was
like a storm and then a wave was like
they would how do you pitch that that's
why I think when the movie was coming
out they were like he's from the
multiverse so it could be a good mystery
oh and and I think they were really
trying to push the hydro-man narrative
yeah that it was gonna be Hydra made
from Gyllenhaal on set looking at Tom
like should have been mean ya know he
was supposed to LA made on Spidey 2 to
replace Tobey when Toby got like a
broken back off of Seabiscuit oh he
broke something Toby he was injured and
couldn't do it
and then they were like well you would
Jake Gyllenhaal looks so similar so like
let's just get Jake Gyllenhaal that's
why they played brothers and brothers
really yeah like it's AB it's a known
thing that's like yeah those guys look
I'm thinking of four brothers which is a
very different
they don't look was a Wahlberg brother
verse will be a cool event but ya know
there was none of that I think I think
he was just there to have fun yeah okay
nice
it's gotta be fun of me to movie like
this oh yeah yeah all right you can just
be like I want to fly out of the scene
alright get the wires yeah yeah nothing
for someone like you with where he's
consoling dude so much he's got such a
busy schedule like it's fun to sort of
pop it you know yet he doesn't have to
commit to four movies he could just pop
into the world do the well I believe he
still is he still alive this guy at the
airport at the end like he walks into
the air it's a really quick he looks
like an x-ray but he like walks into the
airport yeah I think that's growing
again Paul surely I never noticed that
yes it's a it's unclear if it's a like
wink and a nod or if it's supposed to be
canonical I'm assuming it is yeah
it feels like they want you they're
doing like leaving vulture alive
assumedly leaving Mysterio alive because
like the spider-man villains are great
like you don't have to you can keep them
coming back for more movies overall I
think Marvel is a little too happy to
kill off yeah there it's like we want
like all the time yeah I mean I feel
like the behind the scenes is like I
just want to pop in for one right thank
you and I get that but like I even like
killing claw and bang
he was having a great time I want to go
to the circus
all right let's keep going he says a
fishbowl with haunted house powers whose
outfit don't Tony Stark
you know the already dead guy because
even in death Ironman is the only force
powerful enough to motivate an MCU bad
guy dude's company was like an arc
reactor for haters just get a job or
industry to dorks yes continue your rant
I love it I love that the early MCU has
so many great actors that I just want to
come back because they're great actors
like Jeff Bridges yeah or say [ __ ] well
yeah but every movie that doesn't have
Justin Hammer and it makes me sad
like I agree I want like the the school
all the spider-man characters to go to
to be privatized and bought by hammer
industries and now yeah screamer's using
them as a science kid think tank yeah
that would be really leaving a great
asset on the table not having reused
yeah Justin Hammer I also feel the same
way about like Nelson who they set up
all that time ago to be the leader still
acting could bring him back any time and
it would be an awesome so I would sounds
like a contract thing like it might have
just been like oh we could take Hulk and
nothing else from that movie here's what
I think then they got Thunderbird
exactly I think tom hollie needs to get
on this he's the only guy that can bring
these people together yeah welcome
that's the
you said it was Tony snow no just that
every every one that used to work at
Stark Industries is now an MC bad guy oh
yeah if you notice a lot of the like
behind the people either there were
people from the past like obviously Iron
Man or whatever or they were producers
of the movie of like MCU film and
writers or executive producers who were
in the mold later that they gave Robert
Downey jr. profit participation because
he was the first let's kill him cool all
right let's keep coming real as Mysterio
blades on spider-man's
only weakness getting hit in the face
with a trick no you'll strike it the one
thing Peter likes most of all an adult
male who isn't perming out on his ass
you look lovely
you dress yes sticky rice pudding only
cuz Mysterio hasn't met aunt may still
be making the move yeah no I'm also
really happy like a happy became happy
we're all happy for him I think that's a
solid that's a solid pairing summer
fling last summer Flay yeah and he was
like well ray I feel for made me feel
for happy I was like oh but yeah we're
totally gonna get like 500 days of Aunt
May
I could just tweet it be like wrong
there's Disney Plus to do all of these
great ideas we can make it like 200 days
I actually trim it oh man now I gotta
phone a [ __ ] then yeah the rum cut the
one-sided rom-com of June you can do
April yeah
instead of sketching skylines he
sketches like suits it'd be creepy he'd
be using Edith to like look in her
window and ya know some 500 days with
like about a boy and he pretends that
Morgan Starks his kid that's great
yeah the Marvel rom-com generator we
could we could pitch 17 events right I
mean look yeah Logan you got Joker these
movies are branching out into different
genres it's it's inevitable that's yeah
one division we don't know yeah there's
no there's no doubt in my mind all right
let's get the Sleepless in will conduct
mistrust to steal either a global drone
assassination program that Tony about to
a teenager which fine that's good as
thing activating instant kill but this
murder machine is hidden inside a pair
of sunglasses that's the world's most
commonly lost item she might as well
given him a pen full of Ebola oh my God
thank you so much okay so that moment
there was a little thing where he peaked
pockets the glasses and he throws it on
the ground so that way or not throws it
on the ground but gives it to the other
person so she can come up and start
talking about it but I got caught
because they were like you know coming
and everything okay so there was a thing
of
leave them on the floor but I mean I do
get your point about whatever you can
sort of Intuit that anyway because you
later find out that the bar is full it's
like I think everything that happens in
there we can assume was rigged again
that wasn't even a bar right it's like
their hideout it's like surely there's
they didn't right they got to like mints
but I feel like you want to just rent
out a place cuz if people try to come
into the place it's like no no we're
closed trying to convince classes was at
the end of class or the secret society
oh it's just every single restaurant and
then they're all like freeze mimsy gone
yeah okay cool they all unfreeze no yeah
it's a lot like a really according for
my house there's a typewriter in jeans
uh and that's what's what you just
clearly not supposed to go in there live
in like the Silver Lake of Silver Lake
the old spider-man no I mean I do get
your point I mean even flash to take
them out of his hands I when men in
black came out all I wanted was a pair
of ray-bans and they were so expensive
an achievable dream I know they're like
a hundred and fifty bucks I think and my
parents were finally like if this is the
thing that will fix you and I had them
for like a week
yeah yeah the moment he was Hannity and
I was like here we go
I looked up a list or a study and it was
cellphone Keys sunglasses but I feel
like the first two like you don't leave
without finding them like you stop every
right everyone plays a drum on their
body to make sure they have the keys in
the cell phone yeah you gotta see that
this thing stomp cast members we're
actually the Blue Man Group when we're
not doing this we're all in the cage
from make it happen Internet all right
let's have this up keep going
so get ready for the third spider-man
two sets up a second spider-man 3
thought that was over that audience
until foggy schedule clears up in 2024
but no warning because of the right stay
with Sony you get a spider-man movie
every year plus one with venom one with
Jared Leto's Morbius that of web we're
all happy godsword about Dart you know
Daria it was like she wanted nothing to
do with them I do know this well that's
what John works told her to watch just
like lips upon clips of Daria boom good
do I have to give you $5 now that I get
that reference
yes ninety-day Tomei fiancé's uh-oh
nobody telling me about happy in black
[Music]
yes pause now there's like a Hobgoblin
and a Green Goblin and there's a how
many goblins to spider-man have there's
a lot of those are the two main ones
that everyone knows about yes whatever
ones Osborn
yes ones Norman Osborn and then he
passes it to his side Harry and
Hobgoblin was like I'm not that creative
but I want to be a bad guy too
yeah I will also be a flying gun no he
said that's what confuses movies I think
this is the rainy movies that screw he
was a governor he was just the Goblin
came out I think her idea was like now
and so I totally had that stuck in my
head but I believe in the comics no
Harry doesn't become the Hobgoblin got
it he just becomes like Green Goblin
what's the difference between the
Hobgoblin and the Green Goblin ones Ned
the other ones okay great I guess like
hovering platforms Goblin mask pumpkin
bombs ings or so he's just like I'm
gonna rip you off the chance
pretty much something that could do but
also he's incredibly intelligent and he
was able to hack into Tony Stark's suit
yeah within seconds and also I mean
they've left themselves a huge like not
having dealt with the Osborn stuff at
all like this they could introduce it at
any time
they blend that kind of all wide open
for whatever they want to do with it
which is sure pretty savvy right are
they gonna like eventually bring in Reed
Richards as that kind of filling that
role the same way Tony Stark was been
yeah you know you could because they own
all the things now like I think we see
them through high school you introduced
Norman at some point because like you
said you're not in any rush flash joins
the army flash no flash becomes a tough
heart he's not gonna wanna do it forever
and eventually Flash Thompson like
spoilers send they all sighs Thompson
looses his legs which will make you even
you become you become his name old Mac
Gargan who's played by who's in the
homecoming and then I just want to see
you fight Woody Harrelson in a movie or
just real-life White House in regardless
of the guy I just don't think he would
fight I think he'd be like so right like
I'm sorry man he'd barefoot kick you
he's a chill dude but don't test him no
all right let's keep going and every non
MCU filmmaker
you can be the smartest guy in the room
the most qualified and no one cares
unless you're flying around with a cape
that's Oh
you-know-who loki is the darkest
backstory in the MCU Flash Thompson your
son almost died like twice you monster
all right there you go do you agree you
have a really really brutally depressing
backstory but mythos they've been
building I had not noticed my first time
through the movie I only caught it on
the second time through the text and all
caps that's a grim Easter Egg someone
said that it was your idea that his
parents aren't there at the end that guy
who you're Alfred the guy so the night
before I was like that's cool so his dad
picks him up I'm like what is the
funniest version of this moment mmm what
if his parents just don't show up and
and I was you know having a drink with
some of the cast and Jon the director I
was like what if his parents don't show
up and he's like mother couldn't mother
not make it and we were joking about it
and like I never the next morning comes
in and we're like we're gonna do one
take where he's your father and then one
take where he's not and then we did the
other take and he was like nope or not
he's not your father
it's so funny unbelievably funny
frampton like you to be okay it's the
same guy first I was gonna take you to
task for costing the people paying your
parents
this guy thought he was playing like mr.
Thompson maybe I'm part of the mzl
chauffeur but then they they retro
actively put the text and all that stuff
throughout the loan because that moment
glad that was maybe the like third the
last day of filming yes or no that was
the last day of filming so then they
retro actively put it on the other stuff
it's a really funny touch and but you
work that in your characters like the
fact that you have no parents and hate
you is why you take it out on Peter
Parker yeah it's part of it because he's
a fellow orphan and that makes you think
of yourself and you hate that well I
just love that it's spun off so many
theories for you know something that I
thought would be like a funny joke and
add it to the character yeah it's like
so many people are thinking all these
different things like all these
different theories and things that I'm
like that's ridiculous right
I wonder where your parents are like
someone sent me
send me a thing being like Oh remember
that Indian lady from like venom who
worked at RZA meds company who died like
that's his mother and this takes place
at the exact same time so his mother's
dead now it was like okay mom living in
San Francisco while you're going to
school in clown how much like I know
Nick Fury being in space will probably
be something but so many people were
like what does this mean for the MCU and
I was like I bet they just thought it
was funny yeah oh yeah at this point
they've got that planned out like seven
sometimes seven phases I think they're
goofs at the beginning and they were
like let's just do this as a nod and
then like the fan theory grew around it
and they're like oh there are a lot of
like they always throw around those
end-credit moments and stuff like that
like Joss Whedon thought oh this is cool
they didn't have like Captain America
spider-man at least our versions of it
have really played with the end credits
scenes and really kind of just making
fun with them I mean obviously these two
were important or three three three Wow
yeah they're wait
huh three over two movies yeah you just
want us to there's the J jonah Jameson
your suit spider-man is and then there's
the Maria Hill and Nick Fury were
actually space all right that's all ones
oh that one takes so is that one
sequence yeah the sprawl reveal goes to
them called you guys know about J jonah
Jameson apparently that was like a late
grab we mean like they'd it was in the
script and aid written in the script and
they're like and we hope we get J Jonah
what's at stake ASA JK Simmons back in
the script when we first read it but
like we never thought we were actually
gonna get it or anything yeah and I'm
pretty sure he filmed that like maybe if
that movie came in like two months
before the movie came out Wow Wow
farmers commercials green sheep his
bedroom ya know there's like always I
mean that's why James Gunn had five of
them in Carnot's cuz they're literally
thinking about wouldn't this be fun
what did this be fun and everyone shoots
some sort of end credits see and that
you're like I really hope it goes in oh
it's cool ya know well there you go
let's watch some deleted scenes oh yeah
the cut story the king of queens stark
VFX man unstable genius deep fake and
delight and tragic you don't have to
simply by myself in strange and unusual
that's a much older reference huh digit
the grand Budapest Flash Thompson
already my magazine
hahaha this guy again what's his name
Toby such a non presence on screen he
can accept right next to you in this
video
would even notice it well it's weird I
did the last minute as a terrible guy
even though he doesn't actually do
anything wrong
I just wants to predict his friend mg
from doing some weird creep hashtag
justice for Brad yeah pause Brad did
nothing wrong seems like a good guy
about to be a great guy continues to be
a great guy the movie kind of treats it
like we're not supposed to be on Team
Brad right team Brad yeah thanks there
was a whole thing about because he went
obviously he's someone who didn't blip
so he's he's grown into the age with us
right and he used to be a fan of like
flashes videos and everything so he
really is a fan of like it always tries
to like hug him and get in his thing and
flash just hates him for no reason and
there's just there was a moment where
where it was just like you know Peter
and flash just standing next to each
other both going like man Brad sucks and
I'm like right look at him and I was
like oh it's you two like he does
nothing wrong other than like trying to
you know date a girl he almost gets
murdered for that doctors by drones
guild road assassination for having a
crush on the same girl that Peter does
yeah and for taking a photo of a person
in the back that photo was that's kind
of you would hope that somebody would I
don't know about the [ __ ] you don't need
to take a photo but you should tell the
girl that he's having truckstop bang
sessions like hey by the way when I went
to the bathroom I saw Peter with like a
you know I have even met this woman just
spider-sense but only for Sunday's
character says one of our classmates
thinks he's a male escort to to explain
what I did make that connection that's
very clever yeah yeah so they're paying
to have sex with the sixteen-year-old
boy got it honestly trade the the public
revealed that he's Peter Parker for
another movie or two where all of his
friends like everyone he goes to school
with like just keeps coming up with
weird theories that's don't worry
because no one really ever deals with
that well yeah the most most movies will
do is go where were you
it's weird that you just vanished but
like no and then goes like oh you know
Kelly in my class thinks your male
escort I mean it was we on this one they
never sounded tired yeah I want that to
just like keep going well that's when we
do the like Marvel psychological
thriller it would be like everybody's
about to discover my secret identity
see the one where Peter Parker has to
okay they're either gonna discover I'm
spider-man or they think I'm a male
escort I gotta lean into this Bigelow to
the MCU dammit pitching well I want to
Feige answer my letters I think there's
a few more let's uh let's see we got I
know we're all trained by now but this
still seems like a huge thing to put
after the credits all right I mean
that's enormous that changes the whole
that changes everything people who had
to pee at the end like they don't know
what's up yeah that's their fault no
better now yeah like yeah kids aren't
telling you to stay and get like some
kidney stone then the blog post coming
at what moments during far from home I
could safely get up to pee why aren't
there more of them kind of endgame
treatment right every movie should just
get P break it does maybe cuz people
talk about that so often like I guess a
lot of people have to pee a lot more
often than man must be a camel cuz like
I can go a feature film without pissing
my pants didn't go this commentary
taping with I'm like get a rush to the
bathroom the second this is done alright
well then user comments a mad bro she oh
right I love how flash never even
mentions getting knocked out on the bus
there was a we were there was a whole
thing that we were gonna do where he was
gonna have a black eye for the rest of
the film mmm because spider-man is so
strong that even touch creates the
biggest black eye and I was like I love
that let's do it and they were like okay
either we do it practically or we do it
in post and they're like if we do it
practically we'll be having to reapply
it and everything we'll do it in post
and I think they were just like
okay we can yeah we can finish the off
the elemental effects or we could spend
a few weeks on Tony time but there was
also one of the characters does say did
you just knock out flash yeah yeah so
like it mentioned he just doesn't
mention it cuz he's got a concussion
he's so used to being hunted there's no
way he'd ever acknowledged that Peter
Parker they don't even care enough to
physically abuse buddy set friend rights
what villain would you guys like to see
in the next Spidey film and who should
he it should Spidey if anyone team up
with now that Tony's gone so another
villain I mean you know flash Thompson's
venom number one obviously yeah bring
back that like butter me up after that
like last minute throw man you have
enough tragedy that you could just
become a villain without an alter ego
rob banks now you're gonna keep the Iron
Man thing going Justin Hammer I figure I
mean I would want something that is
purely spider-man based yeah
like I like that the vulture was Iron
Man and spider-man with the whole him
dating yeah it's like my date with the
vultures dot and see I'm not too old for
that reference I think mister so young I
think mister negative could be cool Oh
from the game yes
comment yeah it's a comment guys hey
Mary Jane yeah yeah no miss I didn't
know use a comic I thought he was purely
for the game now is that canoer but you
can do it like yeah like Shuma Gore off
the road the tentacle monster that that
thing like Cthulhu yeah its base I only
know it from Marvel vs. Capcom II might
even it might be Capcom it might be a
street fighter you know what I think
that's a good answer
next movie spider-man yeah the one that
people bring up every time there's gonna
be a new spider-man villain is Kraven
the hunter I know
spider-man comics that much but that
sounds really cool I think it'd be dope
I mean the character has so many great
stories and I would love to I also think
he's a lower state villain mmm-hmm in
terms of he's not gonna blow up the
world right which is really cool and I
think continues the theme of spider-man
is a neighborhood spider-man yeah I
think it blends really well too with now
everyone knows who he is so now you
actually have this kid out trying to
like fend for himself all up like a big
game hunter basically yeah sure my one
other taskmaster would be cool that he's
in the game oh right yeah it's also the
square Enix confirmed and he's gonna
fight Joker after that my one other
thing I would say before we move on from
this question is the number one thing on
my wish list Vincent D'Onofrio as
kingpin
see then then you would just do like a
double kind of feature villain and go
like kingpin Payne Craven yeah yeah
- like brilli that thing relight it yes
like that would be but isn't that like
what he does I mean it's it's also like
very spider-verse you just have a great
kingpin movie yeah he could be the guy
behind the guy also talked Hawke yeah
you're right that'll be good no no we
had Alfred Molina who's great but you
know not the emcee use yeah yeah and
then they did a superior spider-man
movie in the comics they switch brains
oh yeah who would you want to play these
villains separate whole new question
right I can't get Molina back I mean but
Molina was great yeah yeah is it weird
Benicio del Toro for oh no he's already
in the MCU
yeah he's the there's only a hundred
Martin started is two people see you
starring Oh Oh what's Ted starring that
was an odd bit Martin and then yes final
thing JB Smoove would have gotten a
solid Pootie Tang reference yeah
everyone's getting on our case because
we got it wrong and we did when we do
it's not Mary Jane it's MJ Michelle
Jones apologies I hope that didn't ruin
your comedic experience sorry that's
that Tony thank you so much
yeah thank you room yeah we hope you're
one we hope you come back we hope you're
in every spider-man and Beyond
you've got a shot venom yeah I do like I
catch up okay yes
come on follows just on my week hope you
don't get a call from foggy for doing
this
yeah drone for being on here just like
say all the scenes they didn't shoot
yeah oh well and we hope you the viewer
will come back next week where it'll be
just as normies and we'll be talking
about well have you talked about what
says I have to actually remember what
we're doing next week it will be Oh
it'll be something where with a fair
amount of rules and regulations the
Apple should be falling yeah look at his
regular nose we hope you'll come back
and enjoy that sans Tony with us I mean
you're welcome yeah you're welcome to
come back anytime
thank you yeah if you can guess it
okay rules and regulation we'll see you
next week yeah thanks guys bye bye
[Music]
you